ali
is with us in houston texas hey ali
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can chris and i help
i'm actually going through a refi right
now i'm going from a 30 year to a 15
year and i'm just having trouble
calculating my break-even point
because you're trying to use the payment
use the use the interest rate difference
what is your current what is your
current interest rate and what will your
new interest rate be
my current interest rate is 3.75 and the
new
15-year will be 2.125
okay so we got 1 875 difference right
did i do that right
uh one six three yeah one one six i
can't do it
okay uh crap i'll round it all right so
let's call it one and a half spread all
right
what's your balance my balance right now
is 358
okay so every one percent you save is 3
500
a year and so we put another 1750 on top
of that and so we're at 4 500 or so 4
600 bucks right
and so we're saving four or five
thousand dollars a year in interest
as a result of this regardless of the
payment
that's what your actual savings is the
payment is
the rest other portions of the payment
in either case are going to principal
so this is the change in your expense
which is your interest
and so if you're saving five thousand
dollars a year in interest
uh which it sounds like with around my
rounding errors you're probably over
five thousand
what is your closing costs on this my
closing cost is between four to five
thousand and i have to bring another 10
000 to the table to get my ltv to 80
yeah but that's that doesn't affect it
either
okay because that that's actually
principle
so your actual expense is only five
grand so your break even period is about
a year
okay that's awesome and you're going to
keep the house longer than a year you do
this deal
yeah i think i'm going to keep it for
about 18 months that's kind of my target
right now yeah it's weird borderline to
score the screw with all this yeah
why why 18 months what are you gonna go
do after that
i i don't know i'm just a very undecided
person i don't know what the future
holds for me so
i know for the next 18 months i'm going
to be here okay
well listen well yeah do do the
reflections because
you're just waffling and stuff and so
you
you put yourself in a good position
within a year you're going to recoup
uh it's a smart move overall without a
doubt and when your next real estate
buys
go with the 15-year fixed on the front
end okay let's not have to redo and
update and clean up
all that 15-year fixed right out of the
gate if you're not paying cash
yeah okay there we go yeah but the way
folks the the recap is what is your
change in
interest rate oh no i'm gonna write this
down all right change in interest rate
that is the only
expense you're saving on right
everything else the payment change
from a 30 to a 15 is a principal change
that's right
but the only thing you're actually
saving is so if you're saving
one percent on 200 000 you're saving
2 000 a year and if it costs you uh
3 600 bucks to do that refinance you got
a break even period of just under two
years
you divide the your expense by your
savings
and that gives you your break-even point
there you go it's a break-even analysis
and if you're not going to keep the
house longer
than that and most of the time the
general rule of thumb is
it needs to be under three years your
break-even point needs to be under three
years
because because something's going to
screw up or flip or something during
that three years
the average mortgage stays on the books
only 5.6 years in america
due to refinances and resales gotcha
okay and so
which makes sense but you've also said
you would not refinance just to
lower the rate no just to lower the term
lower the term i mean i'm sorry
we definitely do for a rate if you've
got a one percent or better rate
difference
then it's something to really take a
good look at but not to refi just to
reduce term
yeah the reason and just run it out and
say how quickly do i get my closing
costs back with the interest saved
right and is that three years or under
and am i going to stay in the house that
long
then the answer is yes you refinance if
you have a 30 let's say you're sitting
on 3
30 right now you're not refinancing that
you're not refinancing a three percent
because you're not gonna get enough
savings
if you got three percent thirty just
calculate what a fifteen year payment is
calculate what your thirty year payment
is right and make the difference as an
extra principal payment and it will pay
off magically in fifteen years that is
true
because it's the reason it pays off in
15 years is the extra principal payments
right the interest doesn't change that
and
and you know sometimes people get the
idea because they look at an
amortization schedule that
oh i paid all the interest on the front
end no you paid the interest on the
outstanding balance the entire time you
had an outstanding balance that's
exactly right because the way
amateurizations work on mortgages if you
have a traditional mortgage and not a
rip-off mortgage of some kind
is it is it's uh it's calculated like
simple interest
how much interest is charged that month
on that outstanding balance
and all the rest of your payment other
than that amount is going to principal
and so anytime you reduce the principal
you reduce that amount of interest
right and it slides you forward in the m
schedule that's right and i want to warn
people out there with all the rates that
are happening
you want to know the difference between
an apr and your contract rate
okay the contract rate is the advertised
thing the apr
is what your payment's based on so any
other points or hidden fees
are going to be inside the apr so when
you call a bank or lending institution
you want to know
i want to know the contract rate and i
want to know the apr you want to know
both of those yeah you can get snooker
messing with just one without a doubt
it's good it's a good discussion because
it's a great time to refinance right now
it really is way down yes but only if
you're going to stay in the house